buh buh buh ba ba bum BA bum bum bum bum
hello and welcome back to the Naraku
location also known as Cassidy chairman
I will be your guide on the tour of the
house today I hope you'll picked up your
maps at the information desk and we're
going to start off on the top floor
which is just this way this is my
bedroom which as you might have noticed
is substantially less interesting than
previous bedrooms that I've had
basically now that we have more space I
realized that I could use the bedroom
just to be the room where the bed is and
not the room where I make all the videos
and stuff so there's not really that
much going on in here if you'd still
like to look around in here we have my
cupboard and my lamp and my bed and my
bedside table and my getting cuddly toys
and my boxes that I still need to throw
away but that's it
so sorry also on the top floor we have
my bathroom which is boring and the
spare bedroom spoiler alert this is
actually meant to be Michael around his
bedroom you might remember Michael
Aranda from such classic Charlier so
cool like moments as Justin Bieber
danced and guy with haircuts and other
things and we want him to come and live
with us so as you might have noticed
he's not here yet he's not here yes he's
not here yet
he's American basically which apparently
makes it quite hard for him to move to
England but he will be here at some
point please Michael I miss you and
lastly on the top floor we have Amy Pond
Amy Pond Homme de route ski the pond
Meister in there on that little extended
platform which is just above our stairs
which er down here so basically that's
what I have to look at every single
morning when I go downstairs and have a
breakfast which is quite nice
and also slightly creepy one floor down
firstly we have the smallest room in the
house also known as the Room of
Requirement I came up with that title
thank you very much it's basically just
a much less magical version of the real
thing that we're going to use for
whatever we feel like for example just
yesterday I was sitting in that beanbag
planning out this video also on this
floor we have Alex's bathroom which is
boring and Alex's bedroom which I would
feel weird showing you round so I'm not
going to do that one more floor down
oan we have the office which is divided
into my little section and the bigger
section with Alex's desk over there this
room is pretty much the entire reason
that we wanted to buy a house in the
first place we wanted a space where we
could be like this room is the place
where we do things in the hope that it
would boost our productivity a bit and
um it definitely has I feel like I want
to make stuff all the time when I'm in
here also in the office we have the now
completed wall of stuff 3.0 with new
additions such as the Charlie BOTS
manual saskia Hamilton and me but as a
Dalek also in the office we have my
little windowsill thingies here they are
up close so that you can actually see
them we have my unicycle which noise
still contrite and we have the crime
phone yay crime phone and now we're
finally down at the bottom floor which
is the kitchen slash TV slash video game
slash chill-out area place Sarah even
more cool things down here for example
the dishwasher it washes our dishes the
magnetic knife thing amongst our knives
and the two fridges that's like a
hundred percent more fridge than I had
previously it's amazing and totally cool
liking right now in the same way that
the office space is made us be much more
productive this space is really good at
helping me waste quite a lot of my time
we've ever been here about two weeks so
they've already made a little dent in
the middle of the sofa where I've been
sitting just playing Zelda for like
three hours at a time basically I'd love
to say for having this houses made me a
bad person
no more productive but really I'm just
as lazy as it was before but now I also
have a mortgage so worth it
hope to see you again soon bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching charlieissocoollike
which meant you like
my my my my my my my my my my my